et le César de la meilleure actrice dans
un second rôle est
Noémie Merlin
d'un jeune homme qui paniquait que sa
mère se marie avec un homme qu'elle a
rencontré en prison et l'aide à le
surveiller sa deuxième incursion dans la
comédie après le retour du héros de
Laurent Tirard aux côtés de au côté de
Jean Dujardin l'avait déjà été nommée
comme meilleure actrice pour porter la
jeune fille en feu en 2020 et comme
Meilleur espoir féminin en 2017 pour le
ciel attendra et elle sera l'Emmanuel de
dready one à la place de Sylvia
Christelle dans les mois qui viennent
[Applaudissements]
merci je suis je suis très émue très
très honorée je salue et je félicite
toutes les merveilleuses actrices qui
étaient nommées à mes côtés je vous aime
et tout particulièrement à nous à nous
que je pense à toi ça a été incroyable
de te rencontrer et de travailler avec
une grande actrice comme toi maintenant
je remercie aussi toute l'équipe mes
partenaires roches dit je remercie mon
agent Louis Garrel je remercie mon père
qui m'a qui m'a guidée jusqu'ici
avec beaucoup d'amour et je peux
m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée aussi pour
Marie Castille pour toi Jacques pour toi
Céline merci et enfin surtout Louis
Louis merci pour ce grand film que tu as
fait merci de m'avoir amené là ou j'ai
pas l'habitude d'aller et qu'est-ce que
je me suis amusée
et je me suis inspirée de femmes de
femmes pour ce rôle de ma mère et de ma
sœur que j'aime fort et de Sanda mon ami
maintenant je pense aussi à toutes les
réalisatrices forcément qui qui aurait
dû être célébrer ce soir voilà elle me
manque merci à tous
[Applaudissements]